es posible que ya entendamos la
replicación viral pero hay un caso
especial que no encaja perfectamente en
las categorías de lítico o liso génico y
de esto es de lo que hablaremos este
caso especial es lo que se conoce como
retrovirus así que vamos a enfocarnos en
él y demos un vistazo a algunas cosas
singulares del retrovirus que lo hacen
ser distinto a otros tipos de virus
primero vamos a decir que es un virus de
rn mono catenaria envuelto y dentro de
esta cubierta también tiene tres
proteínas especiales de las que
hablaremos más adelante cuando cada una
de ellas sea relevante como sabemos los
virus con cubierta pueden entrar
mediante una de dos formas distintas
ya sea engañando a los receptores
endocitosis mediada por receptores o por
fusión directa y esto es lo que pasa en
nuestro ejemplo estamos hablando aquí de
retrovirus
h que entrará a la célula por fusión
directa así que ahora que la núcleo
cápside está dentro de la célula en
realidad tiene que pasar por una etapa
llamada de capacitación donde esta
cápside morada se disuelve y no
olvidemos las proteínas que están dentro
de la cápside originalmente por lo tanto
todo lo que estaba adentro de la
cubierta se libera es aquí donde ocurre
el primer paso especial vamos a decir
que esta proteína roja es transcriptasa
inversa la transcriptasa inversa se
unirá al rn y lo transcribirán
inversamente lo que significa que leerá
desde las 5 prima hasta la terminación 3
prima y formará adn complementario que
podemos ver aquí en color rosa y la
razón del por qué se llama transcripción
inversa es que normalmente tomamos adn
para hacer
pero en este caso tomamos a rn para
hacer de él y debido a que esta es una
cadena de adn complementaria lo llamamos
adn de adn complementaria y ahora la
transcriptasa inversa trabajará de nuevo
en el mismo adn para hacer otra cadena
de adn debido a que es exactamente el
mismo código puede recombinarse con otra
cadena de adn se para hacer una doble
cadena de adn
así que qué pasará ahora si llega a la
integrasa dibujemos la de color azul la
integrasa llega y recorta cada una de
las terminaciones 3 prima entonces ahora
estas terminaciones son ligeramente más
pequeñas y sé que es un poco difícil de
ver por aquí pero la terminación de la
cadena 3 prima está por aquí mientras
que el primero está claramente
etiquetado
esta es la terminación 3 prima y al
recortar estas secciones 3 primera forma
estas terminaciones quest y bass ya que
el adn no emparejado querrá emparejarse
y la integrasa repentinamente removió
esa parte y debes estar pensando qué le
pasa a este a rn lo que le pasa es que
el arrivo nucleasa normal lo degrada ya
no está más aquí y la integrasa hace
referencia a su nombre sigue este camino
este adn de vih en el adn hospedero una
cosa que quiero mencionar rápidamente es
que si hubiera dibujado esto de forma
precisa debería tener un núcleo
alrededor de él ya que el retrovirus del
vih infecta a las células eucariotas
humanas las cuales tienen un núcleo
entonces viajarán a través de la
membrana nuclear hasta llegar al genoma
justo aquí la integrasa ayuda al adn
viral a integrarse con el adn hospedero
como su nombre lo indica la integrasa
integra así que imagina que esto es una
doble cadena pero para simplicidad
dibujaremos sólo una línea este es el
adn viral y a esto se le conoce como la
base propios puedes ver que esto es
similar al ciclo liso génico del que
hablamos en el vídeo anterior
pero a diferencia del ciclo liso génico
regular no será latente de hecho no
tiene ese gen represor que comúnmente
tienen los virus liso génicos así que
transcribe activamente cuando el adn
hospedero se transcribe como las células
pederá cree que este es el adn normal
para rn que llamaremos a fnm viral esto
nos da una idea de que la célula no
puede saber que este a efe nm no debería
haberse producido entonces este a efe nm
sale del núcleo y ahora estos genes
virales están en el sito sol de nuevo
una vez que el inm sale del núcleo se
dirige al citoplasma como cualquier otro
a rn de algunos de estos se traducirán a
proteínas como las proteínas de la
cápside
las tres proteínas con las que empezamos
que son la transcriptasa inversa la
integrasa y por último aunque no la
hemos mencionado la proteasa y vamos a
esperar un poco para mencionar lo que
hace la proteasa pero aquí se forma y
podemos ver que ahora tenemos todas las
partes que pueden auto ensamblarse en un
nuevo virus así que una vez más todos
estos nuevos virus que se formarán
tendrán el adn la transcriptasa inversa
la integrasa y la proteasa pero observa
les falta su cubierta por lo que se
llaman virus inmaduros y a diferencia
del típico ciclo lítico no sólo rompen
la membrana de hecho aprovechen la
membrana entonces estos virus brotarán y
esa será su envoltura recuerden todavía
siguen inmaduros y antes de que vayan a
infectar a otras células deben madurar
entonces lo que pasará es que
la proteasa que está aquí es integrar a
las otras proteínas para asegurarse de
que sean completamente funcionales antes
de que el virus entre a otra célula y
empiece este ciclo de nuevo por lo tanto
los retrovirus se replican en una forma
un poco más complicada que la
replicación tradicional entonces no es
sólo liso génico ni lítico de hecho
tiene elementos de ambos procesos